they say that no news is good news and
that is certainly true today the supreme
court was asked by abortion supporters
to block a texas pro-life law and the
court did
nothing which is the best thing it could
have done because that means that today
for the first time since 1973
there is a state in this country in
which abortion is effectively illegal
this is wonderful wonderful news it
could potentially don't get your hopes
up but it could potentially lead to the
overturn of roe v wade in large part
because of the clever way the law was
written
now the libs are losing it they're
crying they're screaming they're
fear-mongering they're making really
really dumb arguments in favor of
killing babies in the womb meanwhile on
the topic of dehumanization
prominent libs want to keep the
unvaccinated out of hospitals
the american people though i think have
had enough if one poll is to be believed
right now most americans even think joe
biden should resign i'm michael moses
the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from jacqueline tward
who said classrooms shouldn't be like a
teacher's home where they can hang
whatever ridiculous stuff i'll clean it
up whatever ridiculous stuff they feel
like whatever happened to the times
tables and the alphabet thank you yes
these teachers who are hanging the pride
progress flag or the antifa flag even
they
seem to think that the classroom is just
their fiefdom in which they can do
whatever they want and in part this is
because of a misguided
understanding of
what is called academic freedom that now
even the right uh defends the left kind
of pushed it but even the right defends
it and it's just completely preposterous
the third grade classroom is not a free
marketplace of ideas and it never has
been and it should not be and it never
will be it's it's a place to teach kids
basics so i absolutely agree with your
point i wish not only the left but
conservatives would wake up wish they
could hear
the truth and if you want to hear the
truth if you want to hear just good
music i'd recommend checking out your
raikons i love raicons they are a better
product than
some of the other brands on the market
all right i'm going to i'm going to try
to be nice about it but you know look
recons they don't have the little stem
sticking out so you don't look like a
bug they don't
only come in one color they come in a
lot of cool stylish colors great
fit of their gel tips for your comfort
they sound better they work better
they've got a 32 hour battery life i
love my raycons okay
and especially
when my sweet little baby starts crying
you know whether i'm in the house maybe
we're on a plane or in the car
it's nice to know that i can just pop in
my raycons and have a nice little bit of
peace and quiet they're really great
they started half the price of other
premium audio brands but they sound
just as good they actually sound better
if you ask me raycon's comes with a
45-day happiness guarantee so you really
can't lose give them a try you will see
what i mean great way to listen to
really good audiobooks like speechless
create your own soundtrack with raycon
right now my listeners can get 15 off
their raycon order at byraecon.com
knowles that's by raycon calm slash
knowles say 15 on ray guns you're going
to love them tell me how much you love
them by raycon.com
knowles
this texas law is magnificent so the
court decision was 5'4
because of course chief justice john
roberts sided with the libs and the
decision was not over the
constitutionality of the law the
decision was whether or not to grant
abortionists in texas a special
emergency
uh halting of of the new pro-life law
so thankfully the five at least sort of
conservative justices thomas thomas
certainly conservative alito certainly
conservative
gorsuch a little squishy or kavanaugh a
little a lot squishier and amy barrett a
lot squishier but all five of them
to their great credit
voted in favor of allowing the texas law
to go into effect this is a very very
important decision and then you had the
three libs really the forelimbs because
chief justice john roberts was there and
he voted to to stop the law
one small point on john roberts before
we get into what this law actually does
john roberts's whole
purpose i believe is that he wants to
maintain the institutional credibility
of the court because he's the chief
justice so he has a responsibility not
just to
the decisions but also to the
institution itself and so i think what
john roberts is trying to do here is
seem that he's above politics
because he will often vote with the the
liberals
ironically though what what the effect
of his machinations had been
is to make the court seem much much more
party political to make the court cart
seem much
less principled he he has ironically
destroyed the institutional credibility
of the court because he's very clearly
just picking his side based on the poll
numbers based on the politics based on
what he thinks will be able to placate
the people rather than upholding some
kind of constitutional principle
but the principle upheld at least in
this decision the texas law which was
passed in may
bans all abortions in the state after
around six weeks of pregnancy the law is
not based on some arbitrary timetable
you know six weeks in one day and it's a
human being but
six weeks minus one day you know five
weeks and six days and it's actually not
a human being
the the law is based on when you can
detect a heartbeat and you can detect a
heartbeat very early because these are
human beings so
because a lot of women don't even know
they're pregnant at six weeks the law
effectively makes abortion illegal
now
how does this law operate there have
been plenty of heartbeat bills and
they've been struck down by various
courts
so what makes this this law a little
different
the law allows private citizens
to sue abortionists
and anyone else who helps a woman to
obtain an abortion including
some sicko dude who gives the woman a
ride to the clinic or provides financial
assistance for the abortion
the citizens can bring these suits even
if they don't have any connection to the
people that they are suing beyond their
relationship as citizens if they win in
the lawsuits the law entitles them to a
minimum of ten thousand dollars in
damages plus attorney's fees so this is
really providing an incentive
or a disincentive for the abortionists
and for the various ghouls who help out
in this process we haven't seen laws
like this before and it makes it a
little bit harder for the courts to
strike it down it's a brilliant
brilliant law and i'm very glad that
it's in effect the white house is
furious they're really really upset that
that babies will live there will be
babies today
who are not murdered in the state of
texas there will be babies today who
will go on and have a long life and in
10 and 20 years you'll be able to talk
to these babies who are alive because
this law is in effect and the white
house is furious about it they consider
it an extreme threat on abortion um
we've seen in a number of states
republican-led states an effort on
voting rights for instance to pass
similar legislation throughout the
country
on voting rights what's the level of
concern at the white house that the
decision
on texas specifically will lead to a
similar raft of laws across the country
and what is the recourse for the white
house at a federal level to help prevent
this well the step that can be taken is
for the is the codification of roe
something the president the vice
president have called for and would
require congress to act on
i will note that certainly we've seen
this is not the first threat to roe
we've seen in a state across the country
it's an extreme threat and again i would
just note this is offering up to ten
thousand dollars to individuals who
report someone who is going to get an
abortion i mean that is what we're
talking about here so and and beyond
that as i've already outlined
based
to use the lingo of the kids based
awesome great love it it's a this is a
great great way by the way you're going
to hear that this
this law is punishing women it's going
to throw women in jail it's not it's not
you're not you don't get to sue the
women you sue the abortionists and you
sue the little minions of the
abortionist and you sue all the and the
the cads and the degenerate men paying
for the abortions you get to sue all of
them
those are the people who are targeted
here and it
is an extreme threat to roe versus wade
what jen saki's admitting here by the
way is that roe versus wade is a
ridiculous decision
that's her admission when she is asked
by this
leftist activist reporter saying how do
we stop it how do we stop it
she says well what we have to do is
codify roe vs weight into law
why do we have to codify roe vs white
into law because it's a weak decision
there is no constitutional right to an
abortion even if you're the strongest
abortion supporter in the world it just
isn't there it just doesn't exist
and and even
the intellectual and the intellectually
honest
leftists who support abortion
and look at roe versus wade they will
tell you the case does not have very
much constitutional merit so now they're
saying we need to codify it into law you
have to codify into law because because
it's a ridiculous decision and if there
is justice even a little bit of justice
in this world it ought to be overturned
cnn freaking out about this they've
brought on their chief legal analyst
jeffrey toobin
jeffrey toobin has a a lot of personal
expertise on creepy sex questions as you
will recall
he lost one of his jobs some months ago
because he was caught um
having sex with someone he loves on
camera on a zoom meeting with his
colleagues
so
jeffrey tubin
but and that that event involved one
person
other than the spectators so jeffrey
tooman is back on cnn
and jeffrey toobin often like i do on
this show
we don't do that we don't have that in
common but one thing we do have in
common
is that occasionally on air we will say
i told you so and jeffrey toobin did
tell you so when it came to roe versus
wade donald trump ran for president
saying i will appoint justices to the
supreme court who will vote to overturn
roe v wade he has three appointees on
the court there are three other
appointees on the court
samuel alito
uh
clarence thomas and um robert and john
roberts who have spoken out against roe
v wade before although roberts has later
said he supports the president but there
are five justices it appears the three
uh
uh
trump appointees plus uh there they are
on the screen plus thomas and alito who
seem like solid votes to overturn roe v
wade
you know that we've been accused those
of us who have been saying that roe is
about to be overturned as being chicken
little the sky is falling the sky and
falling we'll see because it certainly
looks like the sky is falling now the
sky is falling
because fewer babies will be killed in
texas
don't forget you're going to be told
that women have a right they have a
sacred
constitutional natural right to kill
their children they don't they don't
they don't have that right
but you're going to be told only focus
on this only focus on the poor
abortionist who's just trying to scrape
by and feed his family by by committing
infanticide at planned parenthood just
think about him
don't forget
this involves a baby
and that's not just an abstract it's not
just a hypothetical
there will be babies
who are permitted to live because of
this law
and you will have to look them in the
eye
at least on camera they'll look at you
and you'll see them
and you will have to explain at least to
yourself why you think that it would be
better if they were killed why you think
that it's wrong that they were permitted
to live
jeffrey toobin is going to have to do
that but jeffrey tuban is an abortion
supporter
not just in theory he tried to pay off
his mistress to kill his child and his
mistress wouldn't do it now he's got the
child and he's gonna have to look that
kid in the eye someday
if he has a relationship with that kid
and explain why he tried to kill that
baby
and why he still supports the the right
quote unquote
of people to kill babies just like him
all over the country
if you want to get a real accounting of
what's going on okay not just in
politics but in your finances you're
going to want to check out truebill if
you're anything like me
you've started a bunch of free trials
that you forgot to cancel now sometimes
a free trial is great and you stick with
the service and that's cool a lot of
times it's just a scam and you do the
free trial and then you never cancel it
then you end up paying a ton of money
needlessly do not let greedy
corporations take money that you don't
need to spend truebill will let you take
control of your subscriptions truebill
is the new app that helps you identify
and stop paying for subscriptions that
you don't need that you don't want or
that you just forgot about on average
people have saved up to seven hundred
and twenty dollars a year with true bill
it's a lot of money
because companies make subscriptions
hard to cancel true bill makes it
incredibly simple just link your
accounts and truebill will cancel your
unwanted subscriptions in one tap and
your truebill concierge is there when
you need them to cancel unwanted
subscriptions so you don't have to do it
they got 2 million users they've helped
people save over 100 million dollars do
it right now don't fall for subscription
scams start canceling today at
truebill.com knowles that's truebill.com
it'll save you potentially a thousand
dollar more than a thousand dollars a
year truebill.com
knowles
cnn's legal analyst jeffrey toobin
is really upset about the new texas
pro-life law
it because he supports the abstract
right to abortion and also because he
has tried to pay to procure abortions
himself according to this law if he did
what he has done in texas he could be
sued
for at least ten thousand dollars plus
attorney fees
so he's got a real personal interest
here in making sure that these babies
don't get to live
and now he's going after the court he's
trying to sway the court and so he goes
on television and he says look the
institutional reputation of the court is
at stake here
here we are on september 1st the first
day
since 1973
when a state has been able to ban
abortion 1973 as the year of roe v wade
and the supreme court has said nothing
they have allowed the second most famous
opinion of the last hundred years after
brownbee board of education to
essentially
be violated be of be overrun
but
they haven't even said a word about it
which strikes me as a real blow against
the supreme court's institutional
reputation aside from the issue of
whether this law is right or wrong
a real blow against the supreme court's
reputation regardless of whether the law
is right or wrong
i don't think that's true
you know what i think was a blow against
the supreme court's reputation roe vs
waite
i think roe v wade was a huge blow
against the court's reputation because
it showed that the court was nothing
more than a partisan political
law-making body rather than a judiciary
i think that aside from the issue of
whether you think abortion is right or
wrong i think we all should be able to
admit roe versus wade
was the attack on the court's reputation
and they can either make that right now
or they can persist in error and
humiliation and degradation of the court
there's a woman some brooklyn chick
who's apparently a medical doctor
her name is dara cass and she i think
she shows you some of the hysteria
you're going to see from the left media
on this issue
she tweeted out
get on birth control now
any form that is reliable oral
contraceptives nuvaring nor plant iud
something now
now hurry
so
what she's admitting here is that the
left uses abortion as birth control as
contraception but it's obviously not
contraception because the baby is
conceived and then they just kill it
what she's admitting is there are a lot
of
leftists who are so cavalier about
abortion about killing babies that they
don't even they won't even put on a
condom
they won't even they will that's all
right we'll just deal with it later with
abortion
the left tells us they don't do that but
then she's just admitted they do
beyond that point beyond that point
get on birth control now anything oral
can't never ring i you do something i've
got i've got another idea how about you
just have babies like they do in normal
civilizations that are not dying how
about you just do that i know this is a
crazy radical idea how about you just
like ha be open to life and have babies
and actually fully give of your love to
another person and then make your life
better by having a baby
a lot of people can't have babies it's a
hard there are a lot of people who
struggle with infertility okay
who would who would give their limbs who
would cut off an arm
at least to have a baby
and this cavalier woman you know we are
a dying civilization i mean that in a
very technical way we we are not having
enough children to continue as a
civilization and this has been true for
decades now and it seems to be getting
worse and worse each year and other
civilizations are having babies because
they're lively and we're dying and we're
decayed and something's gone really
rotten within us which is how you get
creepy statements like this this woman
goes on she goes
if you find out you're pregnant and do
not want to be you have very little time
to do it do not shut down this will be
hard but you can't delay call me we will
figure this out together what a psycho
this woman is saying call me and i will
kill your child this is what demons
sound like
okay this is
if you want to know you read the bible
or you read accounts of demons
throughout history and in stories in
myth in in history in real stories
so what does a demon sound like a demon
sounds like that lady
call me call me now don't let it don't
let them stop you from killing i'll help
you i'll kill your baby give me your
baby ah
good grief lady
what this is scary stuff and
i mention it i mean it's so obvious with
her
but you're gonna hear this kind of stuff
from a lot of people you know don't
forget who the prince of this world is
okay
don't forget this is a fallen world
there's a lot of bad stuff here but
you're gonna hear these same kinds of
things from people in the media from
politicians maybe from people you know
when you hear it
one don't be seduced two maybe try to
change their mind three flee from that
that is
you were playing with some bad juju my
friends
now before we move on from the topic of
abortion and get to much more serious
topics
like the wuflu i
i do need to address something because
i've seen it a lot in the popular
discourse and you're going to hear it a
lot more in the coming days as this law
is debated you're going to hear really
dumb abortion arguments okay you're
going to hear really dumb
pro-choice arguments here here's one of
them
here's one you're here
um hey pro-lifer um
you don't want to kill babies in the
womb right so
uh i guess you're probably against the
death penalty then right you have to be
no
no you don't because those are those are
different issues that involve different
moral questions
you
yet you can oppose killing innocent
little babies in the womb and still have
a more nuanced or complex or opposite
view of what ought to be done for
convicted criminals
they're different questions oh yeah huh
yeah they're different questions huh mr
pro-lifer well so if you're pro-life uh
you probably support
covid vaccine mandates don't you if
you're pr if you're gonna be consistent
if you're gonna be uh no again i think i
thought i just made this clear
those are different
issues involving different moral
questions
so one can
oppose the killing of innocent little
babies in the womb and still have some
questions and and some resistance to
taking an experimental drug for a cough
that for most people is not that bad
you you actually can
i know it's hard to think i i was once i
was on a panel at politicon and some lib
guy
he made these arguments he was and i
couldn't hear him that well i we were in
it was a very uh echoey gigantic space
so i couldn't hear
all he was saying but you could hear it
later on the microphone and he made
these arguments he was saying
you know well if you then you have to
oppose the death penalty no you don't
buddy well but if you're pro-life
if you're pro-life then you have to
support all of these other unassociated
issues you don't you don't pro-life is a
slogan and like all political slogans it
represents an idea but it cannot convey
the fullness of that idea
just like you might say you're
pro-choice but you do not support the
choice of texans to pass this law to ban
abortion because
the phrase pro-choice is just is
referring to your support for a specific
issue namely killing babies in the womb
through abortion
there are many other stupid arguments
that you're going to hear with abortion
but don't
one don't get suckered into them because
they're almost not worth your time
refuting but they are easily refuted
because we're talking about a specific
issue don't let them distract you
because i think if you talk about that
issue in particular if you focus on what
is actually at stake
they don't they don't have a leg to
stand on
now speaking of
this dehumanizing talk it's really the
way that the libs talk about abortion is
really it's literally dehumanizing
they're taking a human and pretending
he's not a human
but
the libs do this generally don lemon
just did this on cnn he said that if you
are skeptical of the vaccine you don't
want to get the new experimental drug
for the wu flu
you should not go to the hospital when
you get sick
if you're not going to get vaccinated
you don't want a social distance you
don't want to wear a mask then maybe you
don't want to go to the hospital when
you get sick i know that sounds
harsh
but you're taking up the space for
people who are doing things the right
way if you're not going to lose a few
pounds chubby then maybe you don't want
to go to the hospital when you get a
heart attack okay all right look i know
that sounds harsh
i know that hey look if you're not going
to stop
having homosexual sex then maybe you're
not going to want to go to the hospital
when you get aids okay i know that
sounds harsh
but hey i know that but look
but but but that's what he's saying
that's the argument he's making
and it's dehumanizing
and so we can point that out but
i think once you get it you get it okay
once you get it you get it and you
realize this whole thing is dehumanizing
the whole leftist idea is dehumanizing
it tells you to varying degrees that you
don't have any particular dignity you
don't you're not entitled to any
particular choice
you
do not have really any rights whatsoever
that we don't give you that we the
ruling elite don't provide you
that is that is a very dehumanizing idea
you you hear it from from various
sections of
the left
in different ways sometimes it's
materialist sometimes it's gnostic
sometimes it's
liberal sometimes it's socialist
sometimes it's this but it's always it's
always dehumanizing
okay and on the
on the substantive point by the way
they're also wrong it's not even just
that they're wrong in principle like on
this covet thing they're also wrong on
the substantive point they've been wrong
about this virus
from the beginning
if you want to hear right opinions i got
a surprise for you it's not i guess it's
no longer a surprise in october
our backstage episode is going to be a
little bit different
instead of just tuning in from your home
you'll be able to see us live in person
on stage at the famous ryman auditorium
one of the most famous venues in the
country right here in nashville doing
what we do best
owning the libs
making sense making making sense of this
crazy world join me ben shapiro candace
owens jeremy bourne mount walsh and
andrew clavin for backstage like never
before we have a very special offer for
our members starting at 11 a.m eastern
today daily wire members will get dibs
to buy
your tickets ahead of general admission
so check your email for an exclusive
code you can use to pre-order your
tickets once you have your code
pre-purchase your tickets ahead of
everyone else at dailywire.com ryman
r-y-m-a-n if you're not a member then
you can join today at dailywire.com
subscribe to get your choice of seats or
wait until tickets go on sale everywhere
tomorrow friday september 3rd check your
email make sure you don't miss out i
very much look forward to seeing you all
there we'll be right back with a lot
more
joe rogan got covid joe rogan that oh
that
anti-vaxx misinformer
idiot stooge rogue
serves him right he got kovid when are
we going to his funeral oh he's fine
he's completely fine here he is i got up
in the morning got tested
and turns out i got covered so we
immediately threw the kitchen sink out
of all kinds of meds monoclonal
antibodies uh ivermectin
z pack
prednisone everything uh and i also got
an nad drip and a vitamin drip and i did
that three days in a row
and so
here we are on wednesday
and i feel great i really only had one
bad day sunday sucked but monday was
better
tuesday felt better than monday and
today i feel good i actually feel pretty
good
uh that's the good news the bad news is
we have to move friday
the friday show in nashville
that's too bad that's i actually didn't
realize he was in nashville otherwise i
might have tried to go see him but so
that's too bad he can't he can't play in
nashville but uh he's he's fine
and i i saw people
tweeting about this yesterday they said
joe rogan yeah serves him right the that
anti-vaxx yeah that'll show you joe
that'll teach you what'll it teach you i
joe
all it taught me was that joe was right
joe rogan by the way he's not any of
those things people called him
he came out he said
look i'm not anti-vaxxed but if you're a
young healthy person i just as a
prudential matter i don't see why you
should go get this vaccine i just think
you know it's an experimental drug for a
thing that doesn't pose a great threat
so you're doing a cost benefit i don't
think it's a huge deal
and then he
so he that's how he lived then he got
the virus and then he took ordinary
medicine and
he had said a lot for a lot of the time
that it's kind of like a mild cold it's
not a big deal they everyone said it was
awful misinformation then he gets it he
takes some medicine it feels like a mild
cold and then he's fine a couple days
later
seems like joe was right
seems like j and did you hear what what
he took
oh that idiot that rube
he took
can you believe he took oh i can't even
say it ivermectin why that's that's a
horse dewormer don't you know
this is another meme going around
the libs right now they're saying i've
met you'd have to be an idiot to take
ivermectin ivermectin's not for humans
it's for horses
that idiot he took a he took a horse
dewormer
ivermectin
is is not for horses
horses can take it just like horses can
take aspirin but you wouldn't say
aspirin is for horses there's horse
aspirin okay so i guess you don't want
to take horse aspirin and there's horse
ivermectin but
ivermectin is an fda-approved antiviral
that has been prescribed to humans for
many many years the the person who
discovered ivermectin won a nobel prize
okay
this is a this is a real thing not only
that
i've got let's see how long before we
get taken off the internet for this one
ivermectin
has been shown in at least some studies
to have an effect in suppressing
coronavirus
i'm not saying that it's the best way to
treat your coronavirus there are also
studies that are a little confused on
this that say well maybe it actually
won't and the levels that you can take
it
but here we go mayo clinic ivermectin
this is how humans should take here's
the proper use it doesn't say proper use
put it in your horses it says proper use
take it a single dose with a full glass
of water right it's obviously used by
humans for a number of conditions and
then here we have from the the nih
that that vaunted institution the
national institutes of health ivermectin
an award-winning drug with expected
anti-viral activity against covet 19
this was published october 7th 2020.
not not all that long ago now sure
perhaps some data say well actually sure
it can be effective in theory but in the
doses that you'd have to take it maybe
it won't be so i'm not sure it's the
best thing to do but don't
don't call joe rogan an idiot
because he's taking a drug that has been
very effective at fighting off things in
humans and that has been shown at least
in some experiments to have antiviral
properties specifically against this
covid19 is
you are
as you try to i'm speaking to you libs
you hypothetically out there as you try
to
preen and and
prattle and and seem
so much smarter than everybody else you
are revealing your own ignorance
the same thing on
these these abortion arguments but some
when someone
comes up and says well you're pro-life
you probably you probably oppose the
death penalty then right you know what
what they are revealing is that they
haven't given two seconds thought
to this issue they are what they're
revealing with those glib sorts of
statements is how shallow their thinking
is and the same thing is you're telling
ivermectin what are you a horse
oh you you haven't even googled this
drug okay you haven't even given this
you're just repeating
some
clip of john oliver or something that
you've seen
these people are not to be taken
seriously speaking of taking care of
animals though
how's this for a segue speaking of
taking care of animals
the taliban
are apparently taking care of those dogs
that were left by the united states upon
the evacuation from afghanistan so you
remember this was the united states left
well over 100 americans probably many
more than that
the united states left afghan allies
i've actually spoken to friends of mine
who are uh
either in the armed forces or
have been in the armed forces who have
have been getting calls from
americans who are
stuck or from friends of americans who
are stuck in afghanistan so this is a
real problem
of
christians who are stuck chaplains and
priests of lots of people who are there
so this is a real problem but then what
everyone freaked out about was that they
left the dogs the service poor dogs are
in afghanistan so okay it's not a good
look
the taliban though these pr geniuses
they are their pr geniuses
are taking to the western press to let
you know don't worry we're taking care
of your dogs the americans left the dogs
to get out from their specific places
but
our teams and our officials called the
in charge of those dogs and
today
they came to import and they're trying
to
collect the dogs and they are trying to
facilitate for them and
what they need to give them is there is
they alive and how many are they um
particularly i cannot give you a
specific number but they are alive and
from the beginning when we come to the
front line of front door of the airport
we were in
we were in touch with the uh in charge
of the dog and they are working and they
are
feeding the dogs and i think there's no
problem
and there's no pro this is good news
right this is i i hate that i have the
the taliban have been very good about
this from the beginning they've been
very good
at
their propaganda
and
the west has not been so they held that
press conference when they took over the
presidential palace in kabul
joe biden wouldn't hold a press
conference
so you're seeing here you say oh my gosh
the taliban is giving greater
transparency to the press and the people
than the white house is
then the taliban is asked about freedom
of speech they say you know
you and the west like to talk about
freedom of speech what about facebook
facebook's censoring lots and lots of
your people including the newly elected
president for goodness sakes on january
7th
oh yeah you can't really talk about that
and now the west we can't even take care
of our own service dogs don't worry the
taliban's taking care of it
so
if you point this out if you point out
any criticisms of the west
any of the western occupation of
afghanistan of the afghan national army
quote unquote that did not last as an
army for very long that had a lot of
problems of its own including widespread
sexual abuse including ghost troops
ghost soldiers who didn't even exist at
all they were just it was just a scam to
be paid by the west and pass it out to
various
tribal leaders and warlords and and
corrupt officials
if you if you point out any of this that
the theft the fragging all of
that now apparently
you're a white supremacist
according to cnn according to cnn
quote white supremacist praise of the
taliban takeover concerns u.s officials
okay
now there's the absurdity on its face
that white supremacists
are are exactly the cheerleaders of the
taliban
right i don't know many white
supremacists
who
are supportive of
middle eastern
non-white
caliphates okay so i think probably the
issue's a little more complicated than
that
but even
let's just take it right at face value
what they're saying is that white
supremacists are totally a real thing
that's totally a real big problem in
america the white supremacy okay
and the white supremacists are cheering
on the taliban
who took over afghanistan and that's
concerning u.s officials
who gave the country to the taliban
so that
the the white house officials not just
this administration but the previous one
as well they
come to terms with the taliban and they
say okay you're going to run afghanistan
from now on the afghan taliban is now
our ally don't forget that we're
fighting with the taliban against isis
and
there the the white house officials are
now very concerned that the white
supremacists are supportive of the white
house's policy
does that make the white house white
supremacists does that make the white
supremacists white house supremacists
what is it who is it who started the
taliban we did we did we funded the
people who created the taliban i'm not
saying that that was a horrible decision
i'm not saying that foreign policy
doesn't change i'm not saying it wasn't
justified in the 80s against the soviet
union but we funded the people who
started the taliban through the afghan
mujahideen freedom fighters we did it
through pakistan's inter-services
intelligence
agency
also one of our great allies
which
created the taliban harp which
harvard osama bin laden and al qaeda
osama bin laden another kind of sort of
loose ally in the fight against the
soviet union and then the isi our great
allies were harboring bin laden for
years but then they also kind of gave it
up so please please spare me i mentioned
this earlier
on the show a few days ago
spare me the sanctimony
over the allies and the enemies and the
this is if you're if you support the
taliban you're a white supremacist joe
biden supports the taliban
so
is he a white sup no this is just a way
of coming after anybody
that in any way creates a problem for
the
increasingly incoherent narrative
of the ruling class
it also is being used
to make a political enemy and dissident
out of anyone who supports the end of
the afghan war you're not allowed to do
that the media do not want you to do
that
meanwhile we still have these people
that were supposed to get out of
afghanistan right we've already gotten a
lot of afghans out but we still have
some americans and some special afghan
allies who who make a good case for why
we should get them out including an
interpreter there was an interpreter who
actually rescued joe biden and john
kerry and chuck hagel some years ago
their helicopter went down and then this
guy helped get them out
and now he's been left behind and he
said please save me i'm going to be
killed i'm in hiding with my family joe
biden please get me out of the country
the u.s still hasn't done it jen saki
comes out he says don't worry we will
not leave you behind
afghan interpreter who helped rescue
then senator joe biden when he was
stranded 13 years ago in afghanistan is
now in hiding he told the wall street
journal hello mr president save me and
my family don't forget me what's your
response to him and why is he and other
afghan allies like him still in the
country if the president believes as he
said today that the mission was an
extraordinary success well i would say
first our message to him is thank you
for fighting by our side for the last 20
years thank you for the role you played
in
helping a number of my favorite people
out of a snowstorm
and for all of the work you did and our
commitment is enduring not just to
american citizens but to our afghan
partners who have fought by our side and
our efforts and our focus right now is
as you heard general mackenzie say and
others say over the last 24 hours is to
the diplomatic phase we will get you out
we will honor your service and we're
committed to doing exactly that
i'm sure this is a great comfort to this
guy who's stuck in afghanistan right
this is a great comfort because gen saki
because the white house is saying
they will get you out
just like they said they would not leave
any americans in afghanistan before the
final withdrawal except they actually
did that just like they said
afghanistan would not fall to the
taliban any time soon even though it did
within a matter of days just like they
said just like they said just like they
said
a promise from
joe biden's white house and a buck 50
would get you a cup of coffee
if joe biden's inflation did not raise
the price of a cup of coffee now it's
going to be his word plus probably three
or four dollars get a cup of coffee it's
worth nothing
there is a consequence
to incompetence there is a consequence
to not fulfilling your promises and the
consequence is that if i were that guy
in afghanistan
i'd stay in hiding i'd figure out a plan
b because i wouldn't rely on the biden
administration
most americans
believe joe biden should resign
that is a shocking that is a shocking
number it comes from rasmussen which is
a right-leaning poll firm but they've
got pretty good numbers they've got a
pretty good record
rasmussen is saying
52 percent of americans want joe biden
to resign
only 39 are opposed to him resigning
a full 60 percent want him impeached
37 do not want him him impeached
furthermore
so that's that's really bad in in and of
itself but then it gets even worse
a full 58
do not believe that kamala harris is
qualified to be president
and 47 percent of americans
haven't been paying attention now 40
oh no it's it's even crazier
40 47
believe that she's not at all qualified
to be president so i'm sorry i've got to
correct myself
only 38 have not been paying attention
they think she is qualified
and now
[Music]
this is the best news for joe biden
because the majority of americans want
him gone and an even greater majority of
americans want him impeached
but
americans are so terrified of kamala
harris that it probably wouldn't happen
that's really big as i mentioned earlier
i don't think joe biden should be
impeached i don't think he's committed
an impeachable offense i know that these
days
you can be impeached for
you know how you take your coffee in the
morning i know that these days the
constitutional legal requirements for
impeachment have been thrown by the
wayside in favor of political
considerations but i'm still standing by
the constitution and i still think that
there is a legal
aspect to impeachment and so i don't
think he's committed a crime as far as i
can tell the one crime he might be
committing now
is coming out of the incoherence of
american foreign policy because
we
helped to start a terrorist group called
the haqqani network it was one of the
largest recipients of
of cia funding during our fight in
afghanistan against the soviets
the haqqani network
is a terrorist organization and the
united states considers it officially a
terrorist organization
and the haqqani network the u.s official
headline is that the haqqani network and
the taliban are different but in reality
they're not the haqqani network has been
folded into the taliban they're the same
thing now so the united states is allies
with the taliban but we still consider
the haqqani network a terrorist
organization and we were just hearing
yesterday from from the white house and
the state department that they very
likely will
fund the taliban they will send foreign
aid to the taliban which means they'll
be funding a terrorist organization
which is a crime so i get in that way he
may have committed a crime but otherwise
it's just it's just incompetence it's
just mal administration which is very
bad but i don't think it's impeachable
and should he resign
i don't
i don't know i don't want him to i'm
with the people who fear harris more
than biden
biden seems to me mostly incompetent and
so when he's handling a withdrawal from
afghanistan which in principle i think
still many most americans support
uh even if he bungles it tremendously i
i just i mean that's that's really awful
but i'm not convinced we'd be in a
better spot with kamala harris this is
really really bad news for the white
house when your best shot at holding on
to political power is that people hate
your deputy even more
you're not you're not in a in a terrific
position meanwhile
the left's pr
generally speaking is not that great the
taliban's got great pr the democratic
party has pretty bad pr and actually
getting back to our first topic today
pro-life and pro-abortion
a guest on msnbc who was on al
sharpton's show thought that it would be
clever
to compare american pro-lifers
to suicide bombers
this is a matter of civil rights
having the right to an abortion is a
constitutional right is grounded in the
right to privacy that is within the
constitution and i find it
really interesting that
part of this argument is an argument
about you know the rights and abortion
is not explicitly listed in the
constitution but you know what neither
is the right to bear arms that the way
that we interpret that law is the
interpretation of a constitutional
provision the second amendment and this
we are interpreting another con we're
interpreting another constitutional
provision yet that's we're not applying
that same logic to this situation
i'm not sure where this lady went to law
school but i think she might be
misinterpretating the constitution here
because she's saying yes no i mean maybe
the right to an abortion yeah sure you
can't find it in the constitution but
you can't find the right to bear keep
and bear arms either
except you can
it's in the second amendment and it's
spelled out in exactly those words
she i don't even know what she's trying
to say
but the constitution is quite clear that
the right of the people to keep and bear
arms shall not be infringed meanwhile as
she acknowledges there is no right to an
abortion she's saying that the right to
an abortion is implied by the general
right to privacy that also doesn't exist
in the constitution show me the general
right to privacy where is that
where is that good luck interpretating
that in the con interpretating that in
the constitution you're not gonna find
it
then she goes on to make her final point
we're all like suicide bombers what it
reminds me of quite honestly is a
suicide bomber
someone who feels like they have the
right and the moral duty to mess up
somebody else's life for the greater
good
so the pro-lifers we're like suicide
bombers because you know what a suicide
bomber does is a suicide bomber believes
that he has the right
and the duty to mess up someone else's
life for what they can perceive to be
the greater good
like an abortionist
like
you're saying
to be like a suicide bomber you have to
think that you have the right to mess up
someone's life so what is messing up
someone's life is messing up someone's
life
i guess preventing someone from killing
someone else if that person wants to
kill someone else i guess you know in a
way you could call that messing up
someone's life but let me give you two
scenarios one is you prevent someone
from killing another person
and that is inconvenient for that other
person so what is
a greater example of messing up
someone's life that
or
killing someone
which which messes up someone's life
more
i think
the latter probably does
so this woman
not the brightest bulb in the pack
on msnbc with al sharpton also
not the sharpest tool in this shed
he doesn't get any respect no
r-e-s-p-i-c-t
al sharpton show some r-e-s-p-i-c-t
nora should this woman because the
argument she is making
is actually undercutting the point that
she she is
trying and failing to make
got so much more to get to
but we've got to pause it there we're
going to pause it there on this good
news
that
today for the first time in a very long
time
[Music]
the law got a little bit more just
and
babies are going to be able to live and
they're going to have a life and this is
good stuff enjoy the victories while we
get them they are few and far between
i'm michael moses the michael knowles
show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
borin our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by nika geneva michael
knowles show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 today on the
bench shapiro show a holy war breaks out
after texas bans abortion after
detection of fetal heartbeat the biden
administration continues to declare its
own heroism while telling americans that
the taliban might be our friends now and
don lemon says if you're unvaccinated
don't go to the hospital if you get sick
that's today on the bench bureau show
give it a listen